Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about progress
videos, how they can be an important
part of your language learning strategy.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe click
on the bell for notifications.
If you're listening to this on a
podcast, uh, please leave a review.
Okay.
So what do I mean by progress videos?
Uh, I'm about to do one by the way.
It's, uh, I think four or five minutes
of me speaking, in fact I have done it.
It's four or five minutes of me
speaking in Persian, in Farsi,
uh, you know that I'm on a 90-Day
Challenge, half Arabic, half Persian.
I want to improve my
level in these languages.
So I've done a video
where I speak in Persian.
I speak about my experience
of learning Persian, what I've
been doing to learn Persian.
What has helped me to learn Persian.
So this then becomes a record of
where I am on that date, roughly at
the midpoint of my 90-Day Challenge.
I'm going to put this up on YouTube.
People will look it.
As is usually the case some
people will say, that's very nice.
Some people will criticize.
Some people will say you just read it.
And a whole range of reactions, most
of the reactions are very encouraging,
which is the way it should be.
But the big thing about a progress video
is you, it's a, it's an opportunity for
you to sort of take a snapshot of where
you are at a particular point in time.
And I've often felt that, um, maybe
even at LingQ we should have, like
everyone should have a portfolio where
they can have things they have written.
Obviously we have the statistics of
how many words you've learned and
LingQs you've saved and stuff, but
also regular milestones of each learner
speaking in the language they're
learning: two minutes, one minute,
three minutes, five minutes, either a
monologue or speaking with someone else.
And so over time, this then becomes a
record of who you are in that language.
Um, to some extent my, uh, tutor
reports are a record because I
can go back six months, 12 months.
I can do that in Arabic.
I can do it in Persian now, or
going back to Turkish or any other
language where I've had a tutor.
And I can look at my, uh,
tutor report, which the tutors
have usually recorded for me.
And I can recollect again where I was
at that point in time in my learning.
But uh, now creating this sort of,
um, video record of, of where I am my
progress, uh, I think it's very valuable
and it has a number of advantages.
First of all, in order to produce a
three or five minute video speaking,
uh, it forces you to concentrate.
And then obviously you're going to
look at what you said, and you're
going to discover, you're going
to see without anyone pointing
them out, all the mistakes.
So it is a very good way of becoming
aware of where your shortcomings are,
so that you can then work on them.
Uh, you'll get comments from other
people which may also be important.
But I think...
the main thing is that you get to focus
in on where you are in the language.
And so I would like to encourage
other people to do this.
But talk specifically, talk about
what you have been doing in the
language, what has worked for you,
but do it in your target language.
And I'd be quite happy to look
at these, uh, comment on them.
I've...
depending on how many we get, I may
not be able to comment on all of them.
Uh, obviously I'm particularly interested
in people who are using LingQ, uh,
to learn a language and to hear from
them in their language, uh, what their
experience has been, sorry, in their...
in the language they are learning, to
hear what their experience has been.
Um, yeah, I think, and, and of course, uh,
just as I put this on YouTube, which is
a, a form of social media and I will tweet
it out, uh, people may want to, uh, post
these progress videos on their various,
you know, social media outlets because,
well, we learned for ourselves language
learning is such a rewarding thing to do.
It's something that we also
want to share with other people.
So again, I'd be interested in people's
reactions to this idea of regular progress
videos, uh, as, uh, all of us in our own
way, uh, are engaged in this a rewarding
journey of learning other languages now.
So I will leave you with my progress
video, uh, in Persian and I look forward
to seeing you, uh, uh, come back to
me with where you have done progress
videos and where they can be found.
So thank you for listening.
And, uh, I look forward to seeing
those progress videos, and now here's
some Persian and don't be too hard
on me because this is unrehearsed
and I'm just letting it all hang out.
Okay.
Bye.
For now.